Nếu quà và sẵn sớt này ngày 20 năm năm 2018, tại thành phố Tinh quan và các vị Ná Hàng
Lâm Bình, Hà Minh, Chim Hoa có mưa tò để dứt tò đặc biệt ở Sao Phu Quên
Lâm Bình, 2 chăm năm 2019, Sao Minh Mét, Sao Thinh Tương, Ná Hàng
Một trong 8 mi từ mi mét, Sao In Tượng, Hà Minh, Một trong 8 mi, Sát Hùng Mí, Chim Hoa, Một trong mi bẩy phay Sao Mí Mét
Sinh Phu, Ná Hàng, Một trong mi bẩy phay Sao Mí Mét, Tinh Phố Tinh quan, Một trong 8 mi mét
Ngày ngọt uống cục bộ tả nhiều vị chi trên địa bản các vịnh và thành phố, ngoài ra
Môi lần cũng đá quê sật lời tả một số nơi ở vị Lâm Bình
Tại trường phổ thông dân tộc bán chú thường học và chung học cơ sở sử lập
Lâm Bình, Môi lần đá quê sật lời nhà vị xin xùa xuyy
Thát không tin của nhà xương, học xin đáng hi học tự trức đó mà ngày
Hình cạnh bộ, gió viên nhà xương đang vẫn chuyển đô dùng, thiết bị tương nhà bếp
Môi nhà vị xin bị sạch đến vị trí ăn toàn
Dạ bảo nơi lớn sẽ tích sĩnh ở vị quan và khắp bộ định ngày ngày
Trong đó, vị quan, lâu kai, imai, xương la, bất cả tiết tục có mua tò đến dịch tò
Còn nơi với thái trang 20 mi mét, mùi cơ cao sẻ ra lũ quét
Sần lời đất ở các khu vực đuy nối và ngặp uống cùng chung thấp